The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, let's get started
again on finite-state
Markov chains.
Sorry I was away last week.
It was a long-term commitment
that I had to honor.
But I think I will
be around for all
the rest of the lectures.
So I want to start out by
reviewing just a little bit.
I'm spending a lot more time on
finite-state Markov chains
than we usually do in this
course, partly because I've
rewritten this section, partly
because I think the material
is very important.
It's sort of bread-and-butter
stuff, of
discrete stochastic processes.
You use it all the time.
It's a foundation for almost
everything else.
And after thinking about it
for a long time, it really
isn't all that complicated.
I used to think that all these
details of finding eigenvalues
and eigenvectors and so on
was extremely tedious.
And it turns out that
there's a very nice
pleasant theory there.
You can find all of these things
after you know what
you're doing by very simple
computer packages.
But they don't help if you don't
know what's going on.
So here, we're trying to figure
out what's going on.
So let's start out by reviewing
what we know about
ergodic unit chains and
proceed from there.
An ergodic finite-state Markov
chain has transition
probabilities which, if you look
at the transition matrix
raised to the nth power, what
that gives you is the
transition probabilities of
an n-step Markov chain.
In other words, you start at
time 0, and at time n, you
look at what state you're in.
P sub ij to the nth power is
then the probability that
you're in state j at time
n, given that you're in
state i at time 0.
So this has all the information
that you want
about what happens to Markov
chain as time gets large.
One of the things we're most
concerned with is, do you go
to steady state?
And if you do go to steady
state, how fast do you go to
steady state?
And of course, this matrix
tells you the whole story
there, because if you go to
steady state, and the Markov
chain forgets where it started,
then P sub ij to the
n goes to some constant, pi sub
j, which is independent of
the starting state, i,
and independent of m,
asymptotically, as n gets big.
So this pi is a strictly
positive probability vector.
I shouldn't say so it is.
That's something that
was shown last time.
If you multiply both sides of
this equation by P sub jk in
sum over k, then what
do you get?
You get P sub ik to
the n plus 1.
That goes to a limit also.
If the limit in n
goes to infin--
then the limit as n plus 1 goes
to infinity is clearly
the same thing.
So this quantity here is
the sum over j, of pi
sub j, P sub jk.
And this quantity is equal to
pi sub k, just by definition
of this quantity.
So P sub k is equal
to sum of pi j.
Pjk, what does that say?
That's the definition of
a steady state vector.
That's the definition of, if
your probabilities of being in
state k satisfy this equation,
then one step later, you still
have the same probability
of being in state k.
Two steps later, you still have
the same probability of
being in state k.
So this is called the steady
state equation.
And a solution to that is called
a steady state vector.
And that satisfies this.
In matrix terms, if you rate
this out, what does it say?
It says the limit as n
approaches infinity of p to
the n is equal to the column
vector, e of all 1s.
The transpose here means
it's a column vector.
So you have a column vector
times a row vector.
Now, you know if you have a
row vector times a column
vector, that just gives
you a number.
If you have a column
vector times a row
vector, what happens?
Well, for each element
of the column, you
get this whole row.
And for the next element of the
column, you get the whole
row down beneath it multiplied
by the element of the column,
and so forth, day on.
So a column vector times
a row vector is, in
fact, a whole matrix.
It's a j by j matrix.
And since e is all 1s, what
that matrix is is a matrix
where every row is a steady
state vector pi.
So we're saying not only does
this pi that we're talking
about satisfy this steady
state equation, but more
important, it's this limiting
vector here.
And as n goes to infinity,
you in fact do
forget where you were.
And the entire matrix of where
you are at time n, given where
you were at time 0, goes to
just this fixed vector pi.
So this is a column vector, and
pi is a row vector then.
The same result almost holds
for ergodic unit chains.
What's an ergodic unit chain?
An ergodic unit chain is an
ergodic set of states plus a
whole bunch of transient
states.
Doesn't matter whether the
transient states are one class
of transient states or whether
it's multiple classes of
transient states.
It's just transient states.
And there's one recurrent
class.
And we're assuming here
that it's recurrent.
So you can almost see
intuitively that if you start
out in any one of these
transient states, you bum
around through the transient
states for a while.
And eventually, you flop off
into the recurrent class.
And once you're in
the recurrent
class, there's no return.
So you stay there forever.
Now, that's something that
has to be proven.
And it's proven in the notes.
It was probably proven
last time.
But anyway, what happens then
is that the sole difference
between ergodic unit chains and
just having a completely
ergodic Markov chain is that the
steady state factor is now
positive for all ergodic states
and it's 0 for all
transient states.
And aside from that, you still
get the same behavior still.
As n gets large, you go to the
steady state vector, which is
the steady state vector
of the ergodic chain.
If you're doing this stuff by
hand, how do you do it?
Well, you start out just
with the ergodic class.
I mean, you might as well
ignore everything else,
because you know that eventually
you're in that
ergodic class.
And you find the steady state
vector in that ergodic class,
and that's the steady
state vector you're
going to wind up with.
This is one advantage of
understanding what you're
doing, because if you don't
understand what you're doing
and you're just using computer
programs, then you never have
any idea what's ergodic,
what's not
ergodic or anything else.
You just plug it, you grind
away, you get some answer and
say, ah, I'll publish a paper.
And you put down exactly what
the computer says, but you
have no interpretation
of it at all.
So the other way of looking at
this is, when you have a bunch
of transient states, and you
also have an ergodic class,
you can represent a matrix if
the recurrent states are at
the end of the chain and the
transient states are at the
beginning of the chain.
This matrix here is the matrix
of transition probabilities
within the recurrent class.
These are the probabilities for
going from the transient
states to the recurrent class.
And once you get over
here, the only place
to go is down here.
And the transient class is
just a t by t class.
And the recurrent class
is just a j minus t
by j minus t matrix.
So the idea is that each
transient state eventually has
a transition to a recurrent
state, and the class of
recurrent states leads to
study state as before.
So that really, all that
analysis of ergodic unit
chains, if you look at it
intuitively, it's all obvious.
Now, as in much of mathematics,
knowing that
something is obvious does not
relieve you of the need to
prove it, because sometimes you
find that something that
looks obvious is true
most of the time but
not all of the time.
And that's the purpose of
doing these things.
There's another way to express
this eigenvalue, eigenvector
equation we have here.
And that is that the transition
matrix minus lambda
times the identity matrix times
the column vector v is
equal to 0.
That's the same as the equation
p times v is equal to
v. That's the same as
a right eigenvector.
Well, this is the equation
for an eigenvalue 1.
This is an equation for an
arbitrary eigenvalue lambda.
But p times v equals lambda
times v is the same as p minus
lambda i times v equals 0.
Why do we even bother to say
something so obvious?
Well, because when you look at
linear algebra, how many of
you have never studied any
linear algebra at all or have
only studied completely
mathematical linear algebra,
where you never deal with
n-tuples as vectors or
matrices or any things
like this?
Is there anyone?
If you don't have this
background, pick up--
what's his name?
AUDIENCE: Strang.
PROFESSOR: Strang.
Strang's book.
It's a remarkably simple-minded
book which says
everything as clearly
as it can be stated.
And it tells you everything
you have to know.
And it does it in a very
straightforward way.
So I highly recommend it to get
any of the background that
you might need.
Most of you, I'm sure, are very
familiar with these things.
So I'm just reminding
you of then.
Now, a square matrix is singular
if there's a vector
v, such that a times
v is equal to 0.
That's just a definition
as a singularity.
Now, lambda is an eigenvalue of
a matrix p if and only if p
minus lambda times
i is singular.
In other words, if there's
some v for which p minus
lambda i times v is equal to
0, that's what this says.
You put p minus lambda i in
for a, and it says it's
singular if there's some v
for which this matrix--
this matrix is singular if
there's some v such that p
minus lambda i times
v is equal to 0.
So let a1 to am be
the columns of a.
Then a is going to be
singular if a1 to am
are linearly dependent.
In other words, if there's some
set of coefficients you
can attach to a1 times v1 plus
a2 times v2, plus up to am
times vm such that that sum is
equal to 0, that means that a1
to am are linearly dependent.
It also means that the matrix a
times that v is equal to 0.
So those two things say
the same thing again.
So the square matrix, a, is
singular if and only if the
rows of a are linearly
independent.
We set columns here.
Here, we're doing the
same thing for rows.
It still holds true.
And one new thing, if and only
if the determinant of a is
equal to 0.
One of the nice things about
determinants is that
determinants are 0 if the matrix
is singular, if and
only if the matrix
is singular.
So the summary of all of this
for a matrix which is a
transition matrix--
namely, a stochastic matrix--
is lambda, is an eigenvalue of
p, if and only if p minus
lambda i is singular, if and
only if the determinant of p
minus lambda i is equal to 0,
if and only if p times some
vector v equals lambda v, and
if and only if u times p
equals lambda u for some u.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The second to last
statement is actually linearly
independent, you said?
The second to last.
Square matrix a.
No, above that.
PROFESSOR: Oh, above that.
A square matrix a is singular
if and only if the rows of a
are linearly dependent, yes.
AUDIENCE: Dependent.
PROFESSOR: Dependent, yes.
In other words, if there's
some vector v such that a
times v is equal to 0, that
means that those columns are
linearly dependent.
So we need all of those
relationships.
It says for every stochastic
matrix--
oh, now this is something new.
For every stochastic matrix,
P times e is equal to e.
Obviously, because if you sum
up the sum of Pij over j is
equal to 1.
P sub ij is the probability,
given that you start in state
i, that in the next step,
you'll be in state j.
You have to be somewhere
in the next step.
So if you sum these quantities
up, you have to get 1, which
says you have to
be some place.
So that's all this is saying.
That's true for every
finite-state Markov chain in
the world, no matter how ugly
it is, how many sets of
recurrent states it has, how
much periodicity it has.
A complete generality, P
times e is equal to e.
So lambda is always an
eigenvalue of a stochastic
matrix, and e is always
a right eigenvector.
Well, from what we've just said,
that means there has to
be a left eigenvector also.
So there has to be some
pi such that pi times
P is equal to pi.
So suddenly, we find there's
also a left eigenvector.
What we haven't shown yet is
that that pi that satisfies
this equation is a probability
vector.
Namely, we haven't shown that
all the components of pi are
greater than or equal to 0.
We still have to do that.
And in fact, that's not
completely trivial.
If we can find such a vector
that is a probability vector,
the compound in sum to 1 and
they're not negative, then
this is the equation for
a steady state vector.
So what we don't know yet
is whether a steady
state vector exists.
We do know that a left
eigenvector exists.
We're going to show later
that there is a steady
state vector pi.
In other words, a non-negative
vector which sums to 1 for all
finite-state Markov chains.
In other words, no matter how
messy it is, just like e, the
column vector of all 1s is
always a right eigenvector of
eigenvalue 1.
There is always a non-negative
vector pi whose components sum
to 1, which is a left
eigenvector with eigenvalue 1.
So these two relationships
hold everywhere.
Incidentally, the notes
at one point claim
to have shown this.
And the notes really
don't show it.
I'm going to show
it to you today.
I'm sorry for that.
It's something I've known for so
long that I find it hard to
say is this true or not.
Of course it's true.
But it does have to be shown,
and I will show it
to you later on.
Chapter three of the notes is
largely rewritten this year.
And it has a few more typos
in it than most
of the other chapters.
And a few of the typos
are fairly important.
I'll try to point some
of them out as we go.
But I'm sure I haven't
caught them all yet.
Now, what is the determinant
of an M by M matrix?
It's this very simple-looking
but rather messy formula,
which says the determinant of
a square matrix A is the sum
over all partitions--
and then there's a plus
minus here, which
I'll talk about later--
of the product from i equals
1 to M. M is the number of
states of A sub i.
This is the component
of the ij position.
And we're taking A sub i.
And then the partition that
we're dealing with, mu sub i.
So what we're doing is taking
a matrix with all sorts of
terms in it--
A11 up to A1j on to Aj1
up to A sub jj.
And these partitions we're
talking about are ways of
selecting one element from each
row and one element from
each column.
Namely, that first sum there is
talking about one element
from each row.
And then when we're talking
about a permutation here,
we're doing something like, for
this row, we're looking
at, say, this element.
For this row, we might be
looking at this element.
looking at this element, and
so forth down, until finally,
we're looking at some
element down here.
Now, we've picked out every
column and every row in doing
this, but we only have one
element in each row and one
element in each column.
If you've studied linear algebra
and you're at all
interested in computation, the
first thing that everybody
tells you is that this is a
god-awful way to ever compute
a determinant, because the
number of permutations grows
very, very fast with the
size of the matrix.
And therefore you don't
want to use this
formula very often.
It's a very useful formula
conceptually, though, because
if we look at the determinant
of p minus lambda i, if we
want to ask the question, how
many eigenvalues does this
transition matrix have?
well, the number of eigenvalues
it has is the
number of values of lambda such
that the determinant of p
minus lambda i is 0.
Now, how many such
values are there?
Well, you look the matrix for
that, and you get A11 minus
lambda A12 and A22 minus lambda
Ajj minus lambda.
And none of the other elements
have lambda in it.
So when you're looking at this
formula for finding the
determinant, one of the
partitions is this partition,
which is a polynomial of
degree j in lambda.
All of the others are
polynomials of degree less
than j in lambda.
And therefore this whole
bloody mess here is a
polynomial of degree
j and lambda.
So the equation, determinant of
p minus lambda i, which is
a polynomial of degree j
in lambda, equals 0.
How many roots does it have?
Well, the fundamental theorem
of algebra says that a
polynomial of degree j,
of complex numbers--
and real is a special
case of complex--
that it has exactly j roots.
So there are exactly,
in this case, M--
excuse me, I've been
calling it j
sometimes and M sometimes.
This equation here has exactly
M roots to it.
And since it has exactly M
roots, that's the number of
eigenvalues there are.
There's one flaw in
that argument.
And that is, some of the roots
might be repeated.
Say you have M roots
altogether.
Some of them appear more than
one time, so you'll have roots
of multiplicity, something
or other.
And when you add up the
multiplicities of each of the
distinct eigenvalues, you
get capital M, which is
the number of states.
So the number of different
eigenvalues is less than or
equal to M. And the number of
distinct eigenvalues times the
multiplicity of each eigenvalue
is equal to M.
That's a simple, straightforward
fact.
And it's worth remembering.
So there are M roots
to the equation.
Determinant p minus
lambda i equals 0.
And therefore there are
M eigenvalues of p.
And therefore you might think
that there are M eigenvectors.
That, unfortunately, is
not true necessarily.
That's one of the really--
it's probably the only really
ugly thing in linear algebra.
I mean, linear algebra is
a beautiful theory.
I mean, it's like Poisson's
stochastic processes.
Everything that can
be true is true.
And if something isn't true,
there's a simple
counter-example of why
it can't be true.
This thing is just
a bloody mess.
But unfortunately, if you have
M states in a finite-state
Markov chain, you might not have
M different eigenvectors.
And that's unfortunate, but we
will forget about that for as
long as we can, and we'll
finally come back to it
towards the end.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: What?
AUDIENCE: Why would we care
about all the eigenvectors if
we are only concerned with the
ones that [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Well, because we're
interested in the other ones
because that tells us how fast
p to the M converges to what
it should be.
I mean, all those other
eigenvalues, as we'll see, are
the error terms in p to the
M as it approaches this
asymptotic value.
And therefore we want to know
what those eigenvalues are.
At least we want to
know what the
second-biggest eigenvalue is.
Now, let's look at just
a case of two states.
Most of the things that can
happen will happen with two
states, except for this ugly
thing that I told you about
that can't happen
with two states.
And therefore two states is a
good thing to look at, because
with two states, you can
calculate everything very
easily and you don't have to
use any linear algebra.
So if we look at a Markov chain
with two states, P sub
ij is this set of transition
probabilities.
The left eigenvector equation
is pi 1 times P11 times pi 2
times P21 is equal
to lambda pi 1.
And so this is writing out
what we said before.
The vector pi times the matrix
P is equal to lambda
times the vector pi.
That covers both of
these equations.
Since M is only 2,
we only have to
write things out twice.
Same thing for the right
eigenvector equation.
That's this.
The determinant of P minus
lambda i, if we use this
formula that we talked about
here, you put A11 minus
lambda, A22 minus lambda.
Well, then you're done.
So all you need is P11 minus
lambda times P22 minus lambda.
That's this permutation there.
And then you have an odd
permutation, A12 times A21.
How do you know which
permutations are even and
which permutations are odd?
It's how many flips
you have to do.
But to see that that's
consistent, you really have to
look at Strang or some book on
linear algebra, because it's
not relevant here.
But anyway, that determinant
is equal to
this quantity here.
That's a polynomial of
degree 2 in lambda.
If you solve it, you find
out that one solution is
lambda 1 equals 1.
The other solution is lambda
2 is 1 minus P12 minus P21.
Now, there are a bunch of
cases to look at here.
If the off-diagonal transition
probabilities are both 0, what
does that mean?
It means if you start in state
0, you stay there.
If you start in state 1,
you stay there forever.
If you start in state 2,
That's a very boring Markov
chain, but it's not very nice
for the theory.
So we're going to leave that
case out for the time being.
But anyway, if you have that
case, then the chain has two
recurrent classes.
Lambda equals 1, has
multiplicity 2.
You have two eigenvalues of
algebraic multiplicity 2.
I mean, it's just one number,
but it appears twice in this
determinant equation.
And it also appears twice in
the sense that you have two
recurrent classes.
And you will find that there are
two linearly independent
left eigenvectors, two linearly
independent right
eigenvectors.
And how do you find those?
You use your common sense and
you say, well, if you start in
state 1, you're always there.
If you start in state 2,
you're always there.
Why do I even look at
these two states?
This is a crazy thing where
wherever I start, I stay there
and I only look at state
1 or state 2.
It's scarcely even
a Markov chain.
If P12 and P21 are both 1, what
it means is you can never
go from state 1 to state 1.
You always go from state
1 to state 2.
And you always go from
state 2 to state 1.
It means you have a two-state
periodic chain.
And that's the other
crazy case.
The other case is not
very interesting.
There's nothing stochastic
about it at all.
So the chain is periodic.
And if you look at this equation
here, the second
eigenvalue is equal
to minus 1.
I might as well tell you that,
in general, if you have a
periodic Markov chain, just one
recurrent class and it's
periodic, a period d, then the
eigenvalues turn out to be the
uniformly spaced eigenvalues
around the unit circle.
One is one of the eigenvalues.
We've already seen that.
And the other d minus 1
eigenvalues are those
uniformly spaced around
the unit circle.
So they add up to 360 degrees
when you get all done with it.
So that's an easy case.
Proving that is tedious.
It's done in the notes.
It's not even done
in the notes.
It's done in one of
the exercises.
And you can do it
if you choose.
So let's look at these
eigenvector equations and the
eigenvalue equations.
Incidentally, if you don't know
what the eigenvalues are,
is this a linear set
of equations?
No, it's a nonlinear
set of equations.
This is a nonlinear set
of equations in pi
1, pi 2, and lambda.
How do you solve non-linear
equations like that?
Well, if you have much sense,
you first find out what lambda
is and then you solve
linear equations.
And you can always do that.
We've said that these solutions
for lambda, there
can only be M of them.
And you can find
them by solving
this polynomial equation.
Then you can solve the linear
equation by finding the
eigenvectors.
There are packages to do all
of these things, so there's
nothing you should waste
time on doing here.
It's just knowing what the
results are that's important.
From now on, I'm going to assume
that P12 or P21 are
greater than 0.
In other words, I'm going to
assume that we don't have the
periodic case and we don't have
the case where you have
two classes of states.
In other words, I'm going to
assume that our Markov chain
is actually ergodic.
That's the assumption that
I'm making here.
If you then solve these
equations using lambda 1
equals 1, you'll find
out that pi 1 is the
component sum to 1.
First component is
P21 over the sum.
Second component is
P12 over the sum.
Not very interesting.
Why is the steady state
probability weighted towards
the largest of these transition
probabilities?
If P21 is bigger than P12, how
do you know intuitively that
you're going to be in state 1
more than you're in state 2?
Is this intuitively
obvious to-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Because you make more
transistors from 2 to 1.
Well, actually you don't make
more transitions from 2 to 1.
You make exactly the same number
of transitions, but
since the probability is higher,
it means you have to
be in state 1 more
of the time.
Good.
So these are the two.
And this is the left eigenvector
for the second
eigenvalue--
namely, the smaller
eigenvalue.
Now, if you look at these
equations, you'll notice that
the vector pi, the left i-th
eigenvector, multiplied by the
right j-th eigenvector, is
always equal to delta ij.
In other words, the left
eigenvectors are orthogonal to
the right eigenvectors.
I mean, you can see this just
by multiplying it out.
You multiply pi 1 times nu
1, and what do you get?
You get this plus this,
which is 1.
Delta 11 means there's something
which is 1 when i is
equal j and 0 when i
is unequal to j.
You take this and you
multiply it by this,
and what do you get?
You get P21 times P12
over the square.
Minus P12 times P21, it's 0.
Same thing here.
1 minus 1, that vector times
this vector, is 0 again.
So the cross-terms are 0.
The diagonal terms are 1.
That's the way it is.
So let's move on with this.
These right eigenvector
equations, you can write them
in matrix form.
I'm doing this slowly.
I hope I'm not boring those who
have done a lot of linear
algebra too much.
But they won't go on forever,
and it gets us to where we
want to go.
So if you take these two
equations and you write them
in matrix form, what you get
is P times u, where u is a
matrix whose columns are
the vector nu 1 and
the vector nu 2.
And capital lambda is the
diagonal matrix of the
eigenvalues.
If you multiply P times the
first column of u, and then
you look at the first column of
this matrix, what you get--
yes, that's exactly the
right way to do it.
And if you're not doing that,
you're probably not
understanding it.
But if you just think of
ordinary matrix vector
multiplication, this
all works out.
Because of this orthogonality
relationship, we see that the
matrix whose rows are the left
eigenvectors times the matrix
whose columns are the
right eigenvectors,
that's equal to i.
Namely, it's equal to
the identity matrix.
That's what this orthogonality
relationship means.
This means that this matrix is
the inverse of this matrix.
This proves that u
is invertible.
And in fact, we've done this
just for m equals 2.
But in fact, this proof is
general and holds for
arbitrary Markov chains if the
eigenvectors span the space.
And we'll see that later.
We're doing this for m equals
2 now, so we how to proceed
when we have an arbitrary
Markov chain.
u is invertible.
u to the minus 1 has pi
1 and pi 2 as rows.
And thus P is going
to be equal to--
I guess we should--
oh, we set it up here.
P times u is equal to
u times lambda.
We've shown here that u is
invertible, therefore we can
multiply this equation
by u to the minus 1.
And we get the transition matrix
P is equal to u times
the diagonal matrix lambda
times the matrix u
to the minus 1.
What happens if we try
to find P squared?
Well, it's u times lambda
times u to the minus 1.
One of the nice things about
matrices is you can multiply
them, if you don't
worry about the
details, almost like numbers.
Times u times lambda times
u to the minus 1.
Except you don't have
commutativity.
That's the only thing
that you don't have.
But anyway, you have u times
lambda times u to the minus 1
times u times lambda times
u to t he minus 1.
This and this turn out to be
the identity matrix, so you
have u times lambda times
lambda, which is lambda
squared, times u
to the minus 1.
You still have this diagonal
matrix here, but the
eigenvalues have all
been doubled.
If you keep doing that
repeatedly, you find out that
P to the n-- namely, this
long-term transition matrix,
which is the thing we're
interested in--
is the matrix u times this
diagonal matrix, lambda to the
n, times u to the minus 1.
Equation 329 in the text has a
typo, and it should be this.
It's given as u to the minus 1
times lambda to the n times u,
which is not at all right.
That's probably the worst typo,
because if you try to
say something from that, you'll
get very confused.
You can solve one in general if
all the M eigenvalues are
distinct as easily as
for M equals 2.
This is still valid
so long as the
eigenvectors span the space.
So now the thing we want to
do is relatively simple.
This lambda to the n is
a diagonal matrix.
I can represent it as the sum
of M different matrices.
And each of those matrices
has only one
diagonal element, non-0.
In other words, for the case
here, what we're doing is
taking lambda 1, 0 to the n,
0 lambda 2 to the n, and
representing this as lambda 1 to
the n, 0, 0, 0, plus 0, 0,
0 lambda 2 to the n.
So we have those trivial
matrices with u on the left
side and u to the minus
1 on the right side.
And we think of how to multiply
the matrix u, which
is a matrix whose columns are
the eigenvectors, times this
matrix with only one non-0
element, times the matrix
here, whose elements are
the left eigenvectors.
And how do you do that?
Well, if you do this for a
while, and you think of what
this one element here times
a matrix whose rows are
eigenvectors does, this non-0
term in here picks out the
appropriate row here.
And this non-0 element
picks out the
appropriate column here.
So what that gives you is p to
the n is equal to the sum over
the number of states in the
Markov chain times lambda sub
i-- the i-th value to
the nth power--
times nu to the i times
pi to the i.
pi to the i is the i-th
eigenvector of p.
nu to the i is the i-th right
They have nothing
to do with n.
The only thing that n affects
is this eigenvalue here.
And what this is saying is that
p to the n is just the
sum of eigenvalues which are,
if lambda is bigger than 1,
this is exploding.
If lambda 1 is less than
1, it's going to 0.
And if lambda 1 is equal to
1, it's staying constant.
If lambda 1 is complex but has
magnitude 1, then it's just
gradually rotating around and
not doing much of interest at
all, but it's going away.
So that's what this
equation means.
It says that we've converted the
problem of finding the nth
power of p just to this problem
of finding the nth
power of these eigenvalues.
So we've made some
real progress.
AUDIENCE: Professor, what
is nu i right here?
PROFESSOR: What?
AUDIENCE: What is nu i?
PROFESSOR: nu sub i is the i-th
of the right eigenvectors
of the matrix p.
AUDIENCE: And pi i?
PROFESSOR: And pi i is the
i-th left eigenvector.
And what we've shown is that
these are orthogonal to each
other, orthonormal.
AUDIENCE: Can you please say
again what happens when lambda
is complex?
PROFESSOR: What?
AUDIENCE: When lambda is
complex, what exactly happens?
PROFESSOR: Oh, if lambda i is
complex and the magnitude is
less than 1, it just
dies away.
if the magnitude is bigger than
1, it explodes, which
will be very strange.
And we'll see that
can't happen.
And if the magnitude is 1, as
you take powers of a complex
number of magnitude 1, I mean,
it start out here, it goes
here, then here.
I mean, it just rotates around
in some crazy way.
But it maintains its magnitude
as being equal
to 1 all the time.
So this is just repeating
what we had before.
These are the eigenvectors.
If you calculate this very
quickly using this and this,
and if you recognize that the
right eigenvector, nu 2, is
the first part of it is pi sub
2, the second part of it minus
pi sub 1, where pi is just this
first eigenvector here.
So if you do this
multiplication, you find that
nu to the 1--
oh, I thought I had all
of these things out.
This should be nu.
The first right eigenvector
times the first left
eigenvector.
Oh, but this is all right,
because I'm saying the first
left eigenvector is a steady
state vector, which is the
thing we're interested in.
That's pi 1, pi 2, pi 1,
pi 2, where pi 1 is
this and pi 2 is this.
nu 2 times pi 2 is just this.
So when we calculate p sub n,
we get pi 1 plus pi 2 times
this eigenvalue to
the nth power.
Pi 1 minus pi 1, lambda
2 to the nth power.
pi 2 and pi 2 is what we get
for the main eigenvalue.
This is what we get for
the little eigenvalue.
This little eigenvalue here is
1 minus P12 minus P21, which
has magnitude less than 1,
unless we either have the
situation where P12 is equal to
P21 is equal to 0, or both
of them are 1.
So these are the terms
that go to 0.
This solution is exact.
There were no approximations
in here.
Before, when we analyzed what
happened to P to the n, we saw
that we converged, but
we didn't really
see how fast we converged.
Now we know how fast
we converge.
The rate of convergence is
the value of this second
eigenvalue here.
And that's a pretty
general result.
You converged like the
second-largest eigenvalue.
And we'll see how
that works out.
Now, let's go on to the case
where you have an arbitrary
number of states.
We've almost solved that
already, because as we were
looking at the case with two
states, we were doing most of
the things in general.
If you have an n state Markov
chain, a determinant of P
minus lambda is a polynomial
of degree M in lambda.
That was what we said
a while ago.
It has M roots, eigenvalues.
And here, we're going to assume
that those roots are
all distinct.
So we don't have to worry
about what happens with
repeated roots.
Each eigenvalue lambda sub i--
there are M of them now--
has a right eigenvector,
nu sub i, and a left
eigenvector, pi sub i.
And we have seen that--
well, we haven't seen it yet.
We're going to show
it in a second.
pi super i times nu super
j is equal to j for each
ij unequal to i.
If you scale either this or
that, when you saw this
eigenvector equation, you have
a pi on both sides or a nu on
both sides, and you have a scale
factor which can't be
determined from the eigenvector
equation.
So you have to choose that
scaling factor somehow.
If we choose the scaling factor
appropriately, we get
pi, the i-th left eigenvector,
times the i-th right
eigenvector.
This is just a number now.
It's that times that.
We can scale things, so
that's equal to 1.
Then as before, let u be the
matrix with columns nu 1 to nu
M, and let v have the rows, pi
1 to pi M. Because of this
orthogonality relationship we've
set up, v times u is
equal to i.
So again, the left eigenvector
rows forms a matrix which is
the inverse of the right
eigenvector columns.
So that says v is equal
to u to the minus 1.
Thus the eigenvector is nu, the
first right eigenvector up
to the nth right eigenvector,
these are linearly
independent.
And they span M space.
That's a very peculiar
thing we've done.
We've said we have all these
M right eigenvectors.
We don't know anything about
them, but what we do know is
we also have M left
eigenvectors.
And the left eigenvectors, as
we're going to show in just a
second, are orthogonal to
the right eigenvectors.
And therefore, when we look at
these two matrices, we can
multiply them and get
the identity matrix.
And that means that the right
eigenvectors have to be--
when we look at the matrix of
the right eigenvectors, is
non-singular.
Very, very peculiar argument.
I mean, we find out that those
right eigenvectors span the
space, not by looking at the
right eigenvectors, but by
looking at how they relate
to the left eigenvectors.
But anyway, that's perfectly
all right.
And so long as we can show
that we can satisfy this
orthogonality condition, then in
fact all this works out. v
is equal to u to the minus 1.
These eigenvectors are linearly
independent and they
span M space.
Same here.
And putting these equations
together, P times u equals u
times lambda.
This is exactly what
we did before.
Post-multiplying by u to the
minus 1, we get P equals u
times lambda times
u to the minus 1.
P to the n is then u times
lambda to the n times u
to the minus 1.
All this stuff about convergence
is all revolving
down to simply the question
of what happens to these
eigenvalues.
I mean, there's a mess first,
finding out what all these
right eigenvectors are and
what all these left
eigenvectors are.
But once you do that, P to the
n is just looking at this
quantity, breaking up
lambda to the n
the way we did before.
P to the n is just
this sum here.
Now, each row of P sums to 1, so
e is a right eigenvector of
eigenvalue 1.
So we have a theorem that says
the left eigenvector pi of
eigenvalue 1 is a steady state
vector if it's normalized to
pi times e equals 1.
So we almost did that before,
but now we want to be a little
more careful about it.
Oh, excuse me.
The theorem is that the left
eigenvector pi is a steady
state vector if it's normalized
in this way.
In other words, we know that
there is a left eigenvector
pi, which has eigenvalue 1,
because there's a right
eigenvector.
If there's a right eigenvector,
there has to be a
left eigenvector.
What we don't know is
that pi actually has
non-negative terms.
So that's the thing
we want to show.
The proof is, there must be
a left eigenvector pi for
eigenvalue 1.
We already know that.
For every j, Pi sub j is equal
to the sum over k times pi sub
k times p sub kj.
We don't know whether these
are complex or real.
We don't know whether they're
positive or negative, if
they're real.
But we do know that since they
satisfy this eigenvector
equation, they satisfy
this equation.
If I take the magnitudes
of all of these
things, what do I get?
The magnitude on this side
is pi sub j magnitude.
This is less than or equal to
the sum of the magnitudes of
these terms.
If you take two complex numbers
and you add them up,
you get something which, in
magnitude, is less than or
equal to the sum of
the magnitudes.
It might sound strange,
but if you look
in the complex plane--
imaginary, real--
and you look at one complex
number, and you add it to
another complex number, this
distance here is less than or
equal to this magnitude
plus this magnitude.
That's all that equation
is saying.
And this is equal to this
distance plus this distance if
and only if each of these
components of the eigenvector
that we're talking about, if and
only if those components
are all heading off in
the same direction
in the complex plane.
Now what do we do?
Well, you look at this for a
while and you say, OK, what
happens if I sum this
inequality over j?
Well, if I sum this
over j, I get one.
And therefore when I sum both
sides over j, the sum over j
of the magnitudes of these
eigenvector components is less
than or equal to the sum over
k of the magnitude.
This is the same as this.
This j is just a dummy
index of summation.
This is a dummy index
of summation.
Obviously, this is less
than or equal to this.
But what's interesting here is
that this is equal to this.
And the only way this can be
equal to this is if every one
of these things are satisfied
with equality.
If any one of these are
satisfied with inequality,
then when you add them all up,
this will be satisfied with
inequality also, which
is impossible.
So all of these are satisfied
with equality, which says that
the magnitude of pi sub j, the
vector whose elements are the
magnitudes of this thing we
started with, in fact form a
steady state vector if we
normalize them to 1.
It says these magnitudes
satisfy the
steady state equation.
These magnitudes are real
and they're positive.
So when we normalize them to
sum to 1, we have a steady
state vector.
And therefore the left
eigenvector pi of eigenvalue 1
is a steady state vector if it's
normalized to pi times e
equals 1, which is the way we
want to normalize them.
So there always is a steady
state vector for every
finite-state Markov chain.
So this is a non-negative vector
satisfying a steady
state vector equation.
And normalizing it, we have
a steady state vector.
So we've demonstrated the
existence of a left
eigenvector which is a
steady state vector.
Another theorem is that every
eigenvalue satisfies lambda,
magnitude of the eigenvalue is
less than or equal to 1.
This, again, is sort of obvious,
because if you have
an eigenvalue which is bigger
than 1 and you start taking
powers of it, it starts marching
off to infinity.
Now, you might say, maybe
something else
is balancing that.
But since you only have a finite
number of these things,
that sounds pretty weird.
And in fact, it is.
So the proof of this is, we want
to assume that pi super l
is the l-th of these
eigenvectors of P. Its
eigenvalue is lambda sub l.
It also is a left eigenvector of
P to the n with eigenvalue
lambda to the n.
That's what we've
shown before.
I mean, you can multiply this
matrix P, and all you're doing
is just taking powers
of the eigenvalue.
So if we start out with lambda
to the n, let's forget about
the l's, because we're just
looking at a fixed l now.
Lambda to the nth power times
the j-th component of pi is
equal to the sum over i of the
i-th component of pi times Pij
to the n, for all j.
Now I take the magnitude of
everything is before.
The magnitude of this is, again,
less than or equal to
the magnitude of this.
I want to let beta be the
largest of these quantities.
And when I put that maximizing
j in here, lambda to the l
times beta is less than or equal
to the sum over i of--
I can upper-bound
these by beta.
So I wind up with lambda to the
l times beta is less than
or equal to the sum over i of
beta times Pij to the n.
I don't know what these powers
are, but they're certainly
less than or equal to 1.
So lambda sub l is less
than or equal to n.
That's what this said.
When you take this magnitude of
the l-th eigenvalue, it's
less than or equal
to this number n.
Now, if this number were larger
than 1, if it was 1
plus 10 to the minus sixth,
and you multiplied it by a
large enough number n, that
this would grow to be
arbitrarily large.
It can't grow to be arbitrarily
large, therefore
the magnitude of lambda
sub l has to be less
than or equal to 1.
Tedious proof, but
unfortunately, the notes just
assume this.
Maybe I had some good, simple
reason for it before.
I don't have any now, so I have
to go through a proof.
Anyway, these two theorems, if
you look at them, are valid
for all finite-state
Markov chains.
There was no place that we
used the fact that we had
anything with distinct
eigenvalues or anything.
But now when we had distinct
eigenvalues, we have the nth
power of P is the sum here again
over right eigenvectors
times left eigenvectors.
When you take a right
eigenvector, which is a column
vector, times a left
eigenvector, which is a row
vector, you get an
M by M matrix.
I don't know what that matrix
is, but it's a matrix.
It's a fixed matrix
independent of n.
And the only thing that's
varying with n is these
eigenvalues.
These quantities are less
than or equal to 1.
So if the chain is an ergodic
unit chain, we've already seen
that one eigenvalue is 1, and
the rest of the eigenvalues
are strictly less than
1 in magnitude.
We saw that by showing that for
an ergodic unit chain, P
to the n converged.
So the rate at which P to the
n approaches e times pi is
going to be determined
by the second-largest
eigenvalue in here.
And that second-largest
eigenvalue is going to be less
than 1, strictly less than 1.
We don't know what it is.
Before, we knew this convergence
here for an
ergodic unit chain
is exponential.
Now we know that it's
exponential and we know
exactly how fast it goes,
because the speed of
convergence is just the
second-largest eigenvalue.
If you want to know how fast P
to the n approaches e times
the steady state vector pi,
all you have to do is find
that second-largest eigenvalue,
and that tells you
how fast the convergence is,
except for calculating these
things, which are just fixed.
If P is a periodic unit chain
with period d, then if you
read the notes--
you should read the notes--
there are d eigenvalues
equally spaced
around the unit circle.
P to the n doesn't converge.
The only thing you can say here
is, what happens if you
look at P to the d-th power?
And you can imagine what happens
if you look at P to
the d-th power without
doing any analysis.
I mean, we know that what
happens in a periodic chain is
that you rotate from one set
of states to another set of
states to another set of states
to another set of
states, and then back
to the set of
states you started with.
And you keep rotating around.
Now, there are d sets of states
going around here.
What happens if I
take P to the d?
P to the d is looking at
the d-step transitions.
So it's looking at, if you start
here, after d steps,
you're back here again,
after d steps,
you're back here again.
So the matrix, P to the d, is
in fact the matrix of d
ergodic subclasses.
And for each one of them,
whatever subclass you start
in, you stay in that
subclass forever.
So the analysis of a periodic
unit chain, really the classy
way to do it is to look
at P to the d and see
what happens there.
And you see that you get
convergence within each
subclass, but you just keep
rotating among subclasses.
So there's nothing very
fancy going on there.
You just rotate from one
subclass to another.
And that's the way it is.
And P to the n doesn't
converge.
But P to the d times
n does converge.
Now, let's look at the next-most
complicated state.
Suppose we have M states and
we have M independent
eigenvectors.
OK, remember I told you that
there was a very ugly thing in
linear algebra that said, when
you had an eigenvalue of
multiplicity k, you might not
have k linearly independent
eigenvectors.
You might have a smaller
number of them.
We'll look at an example
of that later.
But here, I'm saying, let's
forget about that case,
because it's ugly.
Let's assume that whatever
multiplicity each of these
eigenvalues has, if you have
an eigenvalue with
multiplicity k, then you have
k linearly independent right
eigenvectors and k linearly
independent left eigenvectors
to correspond to that.
And then when you add up all of
the eigenvectors, you have
M linearly independent
eigenvectors.
And what happens when you have M
linearly independent vectors
in a space of dimension M?
If you have M linearly
independent vectors in a space
of dimension N, you expand the
whole space, which says that
the vector of these eigenvectors
is in fact
non-singular, which says, again,
we can do all of the
stuff we did before.
There's a little bit of a trick
in showing that the left
eigenvectors and the right
eigenvectors can be made
orthogonal.
But aside from that,
P to the n is again
equal to the same form.
And what this form says is, if
all of the eigenvalues except
one are less than 1, then you're
again going to approach
steady state.
What does that mean?
Suppose I have more than one
ergodic chain, more than one
ergodic class, or suppose I
have a periodic class or
something else.
Is it possible to have one
eigenvalue equal to 1 and all
the other eigenvalues
be smaller?
If there's one eigenvalue that's
equal to 1, according
to this formula here, eventually
P to the n
converges to that one
value equal to 1.
And right eigenvector
can be taken as e.
Left eigenvector can be taken
as a steady state vector pi.
And we have the case
of convergence.
Can you have convergence to all
the rows being the same if
you have multiple
ergodic classes?
No.
If you have multiple ergodic
classes and you start out in
one class, you stay there.
You can't get out of it.
If you have a periodic class
and you start out in that
periodic class, you can't
have convergence there.
So in this situation here, where
all the eigenvalues are
distinct, you can only have
one eigenvalue equal to 1.
Here, when we're going to this
more general case, we might
have more than one eigenvalue
equal to 1.
But if in fact we only have one
eigenvalue equal to 1, and
all the others are strictly
smaller in magnitude, then in
fact you're just talking about
this case of an ergodic unit
chain again.
It's the only place
you can be.
So let's look at an
example of this.
Suppose you have a Markov
chain which has l
ergodic sets of states.
You have one set of states.
So we have one set of states
over here, which will all go
back and forth to each other.
Then another set of
states over here.
Let's let l equal
2 in this case.
So what happens in
this situation?
We'll have to work quickly
before it gets up.
Anybody with any sense, faced
with a Markov chain like this,
would say if we start here,
we're going to stay here, if
we start here, we're
going to stay here.
Let's just analyze this first.
And then after we're done
analyzing this,
we'll analyze this.
And then we'll put the
whole thing together.
And what we will find is
a transition matrix
which looks like this.
And if you're here,
you stay here.
If you're here, you stay here.
We can find the eigenvalues
and eigenvectors of this.
If you look at this crazy
formula for finding
determinants, what you're stuck
with is permutations
within here times permutations
within here.
So the eigenvalues that you wind
up with are products of
the two eigenvalues.
Or any eigenvalue here is an
eigenvalue of the whole thing.
Any eigenvalue here is an
And we just look at the sum of
the number of eigenvalues here
and the number there.
So we have a very boring
case here.
Each ergodic set has an
eigenvalue equal to 1, has a
right eigenvector equal to 1.
When the steps of that state
and 0 elsewhere.
There's also a steady state
vector on that set of states.
We've already seen that.
So P to the n converges to a
block diagonal matrix, where
for each ergodic set, the rows
within that set are the same.
So P to the n then
is pi 1, pi 1.
And then here, we have
pi 2, pi 2, pi 2.
So that's all that
can happen here.
This is limit.
So one message of this is that,
after you understand
ergodic unit chains, you
understand almost everything.
You still have to worry about
periodic unit chains.
But you just take a power of
them, and then you have
ergodic sets of states.
one final thing.
Good, I have five minutes
to talk about this.
I don't want any more time to
talk about it, because I'll
get terribly confused if I do.
And it's a topic which, if you
want to read more about it,
read about it in Strang.
He obviously doesn't like
the topic either.
Nobody likes the topic.
Strang at least was driven to
say something clear about it.
Most people don't even
bother to say
something clear about it.
There's a theorem, due to, I
guess, Jordan, because it's
called a Jordan form.
And what Jordan said is, in
the nice cases we talked
about, you have this
decomposition of the
transition matrix in P into a
matrix here whose columns are
the right eigenvectors times
a matrix here, which is a
diagonal matrix with the
eigenvalues along it.
And this, finally, is a matrix
which is the inverse of this,
and, which properly normalized,
is the left
eigenvectors of P. And you can
replace this form by what's
called a Jordan form, where P
is equal to some matrix u
times the Jordan form matrix
j times the inverse of u.
Now, u is no longer the
right eigenvectors.
It can't be the right
eigenvectors, because when we
needed Jordan form, we don't
have enough right eigenvectors
to span the space.
So it has to be something
else.
And like everyone else,
we say, I don't care
what that matrix is.
Jordan proved that there is such
a matrix, and that's all
we want to know.
The important thing is that this
matrix j in here is as
close as you can get it.
It's a matrix, which along the
main diagonal, has all the
eigenvalues with their
appropriate multiplicity.
Namely, lambda 1 is
an eigenvalue with
multiplicity 2.
Lambda 2 is an eigenvalue
of multiplicity 3.
And in this situation, you have
two eigenvectors here, so
nothing appears up there.
With this multiplicity 3
eigenvalue, there are only two
linearly independent
eigenvectors.
And therefore Jordan says, why
don't we stick a 1 in here and
then solve everything else?
And his theorem says, if you
do that, it in fact works.
So every time--
well, the eigenvalue is on the
main diagonal, the ones on the
next diagonal up, the only place
would be anything non-0
is on the main diagonal in this
form, and on the next
diagonal up, where you
occasionally have a 1.
And the 1 is to replace
the need for deficient
eigenvectors.
So every time you have a
deficient eigenvector, you
have some 1 appearing there.
And then there's a way
to solve for u.
And I don't have any idea what
it is, and I don't care.
But if you get interested in it,
I think that's wonderful.
But please don't tell
me about it.
Nice example of this is
this matrix here.
What happens if you try to
take the determinant of P
minus lambda i?
Well, you have 1/2 minus lambda,
1/2 minus lambda, 1
minus lambda.
What are all the permutations
here that you can take?
There's the permutation of
the main diagonal itself.
If I try to include that
element, there's nothing I can
do but have some element
down here.
And all these elements are 0.
So those elements don't
contribute to a
determinant at all.
So I have one eigenvalue
which is equal to 1.
I have two values at
multiplicity 2, eigenvalue
which is 1/2.
If you try to find the
eigenvector here, you find
there is only one.
So in fact, this corresponds
to a Jordan form,
where you have 1/2.
1, and a 0, and a 1 here,
and 0 everywhere else.
And now if I want to find P to
the n, I have u times this j
times u to the minus
1 times u.
All the u's in the middle
cancel out, so I wind up
eventually with u times j
to the nth power times u
to the minus 1.
What is j to the nth power?
What happens if I multiply this
matrix by itself n times?
Well, it turns out that what
happens is that this main
diagonal here, you wind
up with a 1/4 and
then 1/8 and so forth.
This term here, it goes
down exponential.
Well, if you multiply this by
itself, eventually, you can
see what's going on here more
easily if you draw the Markov
chain for it.
You have state 1, state
2, and state 3.
State 1, there's a transition
1/2 and a transition 1/2.
State 2, there's a transition
1/2 and a transition 1/2, And
state 3, you just stay there.
So the amount of time that it
takes you to get to steady
state is the amount of
time it takes you--
you start in state 1.
You've got to make this
transition eventually, and
then you've got to make this
transition eventually.
And the amount of time that it
takes you to do that is the
sum of the amount of time it
takes you to go there, plus
the amount of time that
it takes to go there.
So you have two random
variables.
One is the time to go here.
The other is the time
to go here.
Both of those are geometrically
decreasing
random variables.
When we convolve those things
with each other, what we get
is an extra term n.
So we get an n times
1/2 to the n.
So the thing which is different
in the Jordan form
is, instead of having an
eigenvalue to the nth power,
you have an eigenvalue times--
if there's only a single one
there, there's an n there.
If there are two 1s both
together, you get an n times n
minus 1, and so forth.
So worst case, you've got a
polynomial to the nth power
times an eigenvalue.
For all practical purposes, this
is still the eigenvalue
going down exponentially.
So for all practical purposes,
what you wind up with is the
second-largest eigenvalue still
determines how fast you
get convergence.
Sorry, I took eight minutes
talking about the Jordan form.
I wanted to take five minutes
talking about it.
You can read more about
it in the notes.